l'interrogation autour du plan loup il
ya beaucoup d'interrogations beaucoup de
questions qu'est ce que vous pouvez dire
aujourd'hui aux éleveurs qui s'inquiète
pour les rassurer
jusqu'où vous êtes prêts à aller
aujourd'hui moi j'ai toujours dit que je
défends des l'agropastoralisme que je
défends des les éleveurs mais qu' il
fallait aussi protéger la biodiversité
et que moi je souhaite que l'on puisse
tendre vers une diminution de la
prédation de la pression de la prédation
et je rappelle aujourd'hui avec le plan
que nous avons mis en place un éleveur
qui est attaquée à la capacité de se
défendre et il a la capacité
oui mais au delà au delà du certains de
quotas qui a été fixé mais il fallait il
fallait fixer un quota nous étions à la
fin naples alors il fallait fixer un
quota pour pouvoir vert à l'heure au
delà du héros d'arbres ce dont se défend
toujours ou pas mais bien sûr si vous
êtes attaqués vous des valeurs il ya
plus qu au delà du quota vous pouvez
vous défendre
si vous êtes attaqués vous pouvez vous
défendre mais ce que nous souhaitons
aussi s'est décentralisé la décision
pensez vous que cela soit normal
aujourd'hui que ce soit moi dans mon
bureau rue de varenne qui prennent la
décision lorsqu'un agriculteur est
attaqué dans l'aveyron comme j'en ai vu
un certain nombre ou dans les
hautes-alpes ou dans les alpes de haute
provence
nous souhaitons territorialisée ces
dossiers faire en sorte que ce soit le
préfet avec les agriculteurs qui
prennent les bonnes décisions pour ce
qui concerne leur élevage et la nature
de la protection de leurs vaches en tous
les cas on retient que les éleveurs font
le droit de se dé les branques ans et je
voudrais aussi que indépendamment du
plan loup alors un nom pas d'aller
au-delà du quota au delà du quota mais
que lorsque vous êtes attaqués vous
pouvez vous défendre
je pense que les choses sont claires oui
il ya un quota qui a été mis parce qu'il
fallait fixer un quota
cependant ce que je veux vous dire c'est
que nous sommes avec ce nouveau plan
loup c'est un compromis qui a été bâtie
entre les uns et les autres et qui nous
permet aujourd'hui d'avoir une
visibilité sur 6 mois et dans six mois
nous ferons un rapport sur je dirais le
l'exercice de ces six mois et nous
verrons si nous devons adapter ou
modifier un certain nombre de choses